bella
a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi che sono parigi oggi sono tornati
sulle pubblicità proprio quelle proprio
quelle non italiane ma quelle fatte bene
allora voglia di giappone mi sale ogni 4
minuti di più visto che riguardo si
video che fa ci sono gli unici video che
rifaccio che riguardo a manetta perché
sono talmente bello da riguardare sempre
sti video però anche voi ogni volta che
registra subito per sono contentissimo
perché ogni volta miss so che starò per
stupire la mia persona in una maniera
incredibile pubblicità giapponesi di
oggi
la partenza è buona ragazzi c'è pac man
e versione gigante che offre un ombrello
chiuso mentre piove che incoraggia la
corsa è una pubblicità di patatine da
una bibita visita quando non sai
un'abilità non è proprio cosa vedo cosa
nello the human centipede sapervi per
infermi periodo ho capito cosa era ma
chi se ne frega
questa scena questa c'è guarda quanto è
contento lui guarda quanto è contento
una barbie
vi prego guarda guardano proprio
soddisfatto in una maniera pazzesca
non ho capito una sega di che cos'era ma
va bene è un mix di pelati chiedo solo
cosa era il mais ma che schifo quale
action si può ricavare da che me la più
fedele mi ammazzerei perché non sono
andato l'ultima volta non ci sono andati
però certo montagne russe senza la
montagna russa va bene
[Musica]
questa comunque è riuscito oggi a riva
starr è stata una mia ragazzi cosa mi
sono perso perché non ci sono andato
maledizione sei games questa marca che
c'ha io ho detto sul nostro piedi video
splendido lo compro questa roba
ok il grande per le fantasie di melo
scusami scarambone fantasia saperlo
player o queste l'odore che c'è il m fa
schifo lo so la gente fa schifo però si
no vi prego vi immaginate uno che vi
immaginate st scena c'è uno che in me
tra un buon odore di gatti fanno guarda
la sua faccia come appagata da questa
gol a questi sono queste sono le cure
lino che hanno fatto four minutes sono
four e no non è vero ma forse detto una
cagata
però mi hanno tutti right at t 2
[Musica]
cos'hai rappresentava va bene ma non
c'era il sonno degli snack alla frusta
la vedo che li compra
no il calippo il calippo giapponese
sapeva di incredibile il menù come o
succedendo a napoli va
ma si sa il carico khalip cosca plico
vabbè vai vai vai vai vai a fare in culo
a parigi anche c'è città in connessione
con il dito al campo fino a una ragazza
mi piace in avanti quando ci sarà il
viso contro alleati ma per i ragazzi di
tutti gli spot musica musicali che fanno
da notare i movimenti strani tipo per
ripetuti tra l'altro è come se avessero
un meme per ogni singolo riuscito
nisticò pubblicità stanza
[Musica]
riguardo riguardo
può sono diventati due co che tra
l'altro ha fatte anche male perché non
era molto graduale ma erano dell'egitto
cana è sciolta oggi su vicini g al male
combini ok al team di marco che era
combini è cominciato lì consarino con la
roma si ritrova di una nuvola ma certo
ma certo ma mangiamo nudi e crudi marsi
capo di single punti the rise of two
questo è lewis e vabbè guardiamo avanti
[Musica]
l'intro di un'anima e bellissimo che non
ho ancora visto ma che voglio vedere
girone bucchero sexton non ho capito
ciao
[Musica]
sange il mirino si muovono coppia
ok forse non dovevo fare questa cosa no
vi prego le partite giganti noi abbiamo
fatto questa cosa ma ricordo ed aver mai
uguali o si notano c'è una banana nera
ecm suite da riso come un leader e solo
se non ho capito però barabba nava no
ragazzi io non so non si fanno gli altri
non me lo spiego io lo giuro
se ciresce una motivazione che non mi
sto trovando ma cos'è di station
porca vacca voglio più potere scherzavo
ma cosa vuol dire cos'era perché
[Musica]
ragazze mi state vendendo un fast food
vi ammazzo meno male che la coca cola
non c'entra niente con gli hamburger
dietro ma va bene
ecco già ho tantissime domande ne ho
veramente tante
cos'è cos'è lo voglio abitate fatta al
computer immagino che non penso di sì
oddio ma scagliate your name sembrava ci
facevano qui nella capitale
[Musica]
sì però stai calmo va bene andiamo
avanti fa giocano a tennis imputare la
scuola e che è fantastico anche vorrei
farlo però è un tennis per telefono va
bene non si vede che sei in playback
cos'è sta roba niente più auto nei
cookie pensioni ma così no mio dio
[Musica]
io non so cosa dire però c'è un gatto va
bene
bellissimo
ma cosa vedo grande successo
[Musica]
vestito in amia natale k7 che devasta
anch'io voglio un luchador che mi cucina
le uova si può chiedere ai ragazzi
questa era vista erano puntati di oggi
puntate le pubblicità volevo dire vabbè
dopo tutte ste robe posso anche avere
cervello in pappa è la conseguenza
purtroppo però il video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi lasciato un bel laiche subito è
piaciuto iscritte che canalis piace
dalla campania in.hub rimanere
aggiornati arriveranno nuovi video sulle
nazioni di turisti giapponesi bei
ragazzi
[Musica]